welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down fast X
the drama surrounding it and also its
ending the movie packs a big post credit
scene that sees a major character
returning and there's lots to talk about
both on and off camera has the franchise
hit rock bottom can you smell what Vin
Diesel's been cooking well we can and we
have some theories on where it's gonna
all be going no point in issuing a
spoiler warning now as we we have kind
of ruined it but I question what kind of
person you are if you click an ending
explain video and then get angry that
people talk about the ending you're
dead and the movie closes out
with a rock returning to the franchise
despite saying that he never would the
family feud between the pair has gone on
for the best part of a decade and I'm
guessing that the Black Adam box office
made him realize he was stuck between a
rock and a hard place I'm just picturing
Vin Diesel sitting like Thanos and
saying you could not live with your own
failure
where did that bring you
back to me
you don't turn your back on family but
it's been a long road for us to get to
this point everything started back in
2016 when The Rock put out and now
deleted Instagram post referring to
certain cast members as and I quote
candy asses the whole post said some
male co-stars conduct themselves as
stand of men and true professionals
While others don't the ones that don't
are too chicken to do anything about it
anyway candy asses when you watch the
movie Next April and it seems like I'm
not acting in some of these scenes and
my blood is legit boiling you're right
nigida rumors of diesel being difficult
to work with people instantly assumed it
was him and the rock made things worse a
couple days after filming wrapped in
another Instagram post the rock thank
dollars are the cast mates by name but
he didn't mention or refer to diesel at
all like a garage that only sells
unleaded
Michelle Rodriguez later confirmed the
onset tension though she chalk it up to
them being a big family that sometimes
argue that's not a family joke I swear
she legitimately said that now on the
other side of this we had Diesel's
longtime co-star Tyrese Gibson blaming
the rock for the delays of past nine he
said congratulations to the Rock and
your brother-in-law AKA seven bucks
producing partner but making the Fast
and the Furious franchise about you this
raised a lot of people's eyebrows but
diesel Defender Johnson by saying the
delays weren't one person's fault the
rock did go on to get his own spin-off
in Hobson Shore which was pretty well
received this seemed to calm things down
a bit with Dwayne saying that family
were gonna have a difference of opinion
on fundamental core beliefs he said that
conflict could be good if it was
followed by a great resolution and later
on stated that though Universal would
have probably been happier if it never
happened on set that actually helped
interest in the film so it worked out
for the best diesel was being diplomatic
too by saying that he was using tough
love to get the performance in Dwayne to
be where it needed to go things seemed
to die down however the rock didn't end
up appearing in and past nine and it was
that during pre-production that things
were stuck between a rock and a hard
place I said that already but Johnson
posted that he wished them all well on
fast 10 and 11 but unfortunately that he
wouldn't be returning to the franchise
later on in an interview he said he
laughed at the tough love comments but
did say that he regretted things looking
back on the feud in a 2021 interview
with Vanity Fair he said he did regret
putting out the original post there
however he doubled down and said that he
wouldn't take it back and that he meant
what he said it was just bad it was out
there publicly the fire kept getting
fuel with jokes about diesel showing up
in red notice and The Rock denying ever
returning to the fast films over and
over and over again eventually though
diesel extended an olive branch and put
out a big post on Instagram asking him
to return it said my little brother
Dwayne the time has come the world
awaits the finale of first 10. as you
know my children refer to you as uncle
Dwayne in my house there's not a holiday
that goes by the day and you don't don't
send well wishes but the time has come
Legacy awaits I told you years ago I was
gonna fulfill my promise to Pablo I
swore that we would reach and manifest
the best fast in the finale that is fast
10. I say this out of love but you must
show up do not leave the franchise Idol
you have a very important role to play
hubs can be played by no other I hope
that you rise to the occasion and
fulfill your destiny I am Groot oh that
The Rock responded shortly after saying
that he didn't like that Paul Walker was
brought into it as Dwayne felt he should
have been left out of it he also said
that he made it abundantly clear
directly that he would not be coming
back then the hierarchy of power in the
DC Universe changed and we none know
that Hobbes has returned it's probably
going to be conspiracy theories that
this was a big Pia Austin to get people
interested in his eventual return but
let me know below exactly what you think
the scene itself follows the SWAT team
breaking into a dark and abandoned
location eventually one of them makes
their way feather into it and we see a
TV screen playing an old 70s sing-along
of what I believe is Doris Day and Paul
Watson the song is till we meet again
and originally it was about a soldier
who had to go up and fight in the Great
War and thus he was singing along with
his love here though it's about the
incoming battle between the two
characters and how they'll meet again at
some point down the line in front of the
TVs are ringing phone and the lead SWAT
team member answers this which is when
we get none other than the voice of
Jason momoa's Dante Reyes we then get a
flashback of the moment when Dom crashed
the car into his father's ride and this
happened during Fast Five this show that
Hobbs was actually the one that killed
his dear old dad and this is what Dante
Wants Revenge for as he arrived on the
floor saying Help Me Hobbs got out the
car and then shot and killed him which
is why Dante is now seeking Vengeance
Dante then turns him by saying that the
devil's coming for him which and I say
this every video These Days could be an
odd to Dante's Inferno I know prices for
guessing that the SWAT team members
actually Hobbs and he then masks to
reveal his face his goatee is back at
which I'm not kidding people complained
about not being in Hobson's Shore he
then says I'm ready you son before
he crushes the phone in his hand and we
get the end of the scene at the moment
the most obvious thing that could happen
is that this gets addressed in the next
fast film and Vin Diesel has confirmed
that they are making a Trilogy he said I
can say this
uh
going into making this movie the the
studio had asked if this could be a
two-parter
and after the studio saw this part one
they said could you make fast X the
finale a trilogy
so
um it's three acts in any story so are
you guys confirming right now that we're
getting a third movie wait did that just
happen wait wait where are you guys
going are you kidding me right now you
guys heard it here first we might be
getting a third move so yeah most
obvious thing is that we go in this
direction however I also think that we
could potentially explore things in
Hobson Shore too Dante showed in the
movie that he tends to go after people's
family and I think that would be the
best place to explore it that might not
happen though as we did get an update on
the spin-off in December that said
there'd be no conversations had about it
I bet the rock also said he wouldn't
come back and I can imagine that this
post-create scene was likely filmed at
the last minute Mamoa didn't even need
to get back in the room for it and a lot
of it could be done very very easily we
saw a similar thing with Henry cavill's
Superman where his scene was shot last
minute and it might have been a summer
thing here too they could have reignited
the talks about the spin-off and the
reports saying that things had stalled
happened back at the start of December
2022 so six months is a long time in
Hollywood now it's also possible that
there is no more conversations about it
because they've decided to incorporate
the plot of that film into the next fast
movie that would also allow to go from a
2 two-parter to a Trilogy and we could
center on Reyes going after the rock
store the next time and then finally get
the group teaming up a fast XXX yes I
have seen comments saying that Vin
Diesel's master plan has been to bring
his triple X franchise in the Fast and
the Furious together and if he's done it
you some so yeah that's how I
think things will go and I think it
would make the most sense to have
hobbs's door in danger and that will
keep things centralized instead of them
having to include the 500 of the
characters that are now part of the
franchise summer is coming are you ready
manscaped is here to make sure your
body's ready for the wild with their
game-changing full body and grooming
hygiene products don't be the guy at the
beach with the Austin power chest hey
you chump and if you grew some winter
man tits which will all did make sure at
least they're hairless yet no one wants
to say that it's time to get ready for
summer and if you use the code heavy
spoilers at checkout you get free
shipping and 20 off right now manscape
the dedicated to helping you up your
game and offering an amazing deal on the
performance pack package 4.0 as always
the kit comes with the essential
lawnmower 4.0 users every week it's got
a 4000k LED flashlight on it so you can
trim up as you're shaving it's also got
a travel lock function as well so you
don't set it off when you're on the go
and to add to that it's also waterproof
the trimmers also got Advanced Skin safe
technology so it massively helps to
reduce Nicks and cuts alongside it is
also the weed whacker 2.0 you know we
had to throw this in as well and this is
just an amazing nose and ear trim out
that getting deep and gets those dirty
hairs out now inside the performance
package you'll also find the crop
preservable deodorant and the crop
reviver toner spray inside the kit
you'll also get the shed travel bag
along with the anti-chafing manscape
boxes if you're wearing sandals as well
you can get the shears 2.0 to help trim
up those nails and yeah the guys the
thought of everything having the right
tools for grooming is essential
especially with Summer coming up so make
sure you go to manscape.com heavy
spoilers and enter the code heavy
spoilers at checkout for 20 off and free
shipping That's manscape.com Heavy
spoilers heavy spoilers at the checkout
for 20 off and free shipping I'll see
you on the beach you Beach as for the
rest of the movie outside all this stuff
with The Rock the film also had a bit of
a disastrous time when it was in
production Justin Lin started off as a
director but when Vin Diesel released
the video with him people started to
suspect that something was off whole
thing was legitimately like a hostage
video with Lynn blinking in Morse code
to try and let people know that he was
being held against his will what do you
think Justin
week one this friendship week one how
does it feel
s like the beginning of uh of an epic
ending
is it fair to say that this will be the
best one
in my heart yes
[Music]
I think as well
now though Vin Diesel had him held down
and fortunately he wasn't meant to be as
Linux said it shortly after this Judo
what was said to be a quote-unquote
major disagreement according to report
it was a Saturday to remember that start
with Lynn talking about notes with his
fellow franchise producer however this
then escalated and Linda part of the
project during this meeting his parting
words were apparently this movie is not
worth my mental health and the whole
thing ended with a door slamming
apparently he was angered that diesel
showed up to set light and out of shape
and that he also hadn't bothered to
learn his lines on the other side of
this sources close to Universal said
diesel had been worried about the
spiraling budget and that to the studio
he was simultaneously their greatest
star and also their biggest headache
probably get the video blocked by
Universal for saying that but they were
gonna copyright claim it anyway so
them in the stupid prince in the
copyright office I just sit there and
bitterly claim YouTube reviews all day
because their dreams of working in the
movie industry turn out to be as as
their higher personality
anyway diesel apparently wouldn't stop
reminding people of how important the
fast franchise was to the film industry
and thus the ego he brings with it is
said to have caused a lot of issues this
had major repercussions in trying to get
replacement director and James 1
apparently wouldn't come back due to his
strain relationship after fast seven in
the end Louis lataria took over and that
brings us to the movie itself the film
Sanders around Vin Diesel saying family
far more often than usual and in all
honesty it feels like the franchise
doesn't have much gas in the tank left
as constant callback surprise films with
Fast Five being a very strong focus 6-7
in the fate of the Furious also get
heavy knots as well and at points of
fuels like they're going back around the
racetrack again and passing by things
we've already seen the phrase just
playing their greatest hits Springs to
mind and we kind of hit a point where
these movies need to start innovating
now before the trailer for the movie
released I jokingly said that Fast and
the Furious movies will have you
thinking that once you you hate your 20s
you never meet anybody new and everyone
you come across is just someone from
your past that turned out to be the case
as well and I don't know why they can't
just be like here's a new character that
no one's ever met before don't you worry
about it when I heard about how Joker
tied in with the Wayne's I thought that
was a bit stupid because you don't need
to tie every character in with every
character's backstory however I thought
they did that well in the final product
and to be fair fast X does do it well
with Dante Reyes as well Momoa tears up
the scenery and it feels like the movie
finally begins once he enters the
picture I had heard in advance that he
was a bit over the top but even that
didn't prepare me for how campy was guy
was like a pantomime villain and you
know what it was hilarious now
in the movie we learn he's been planning
to torch it down for what happened to
his father and the group head out to
Rome which is where he frames the famous
terrorists after they try and get rid of
a bomb
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb the Gang has split up and they run
into some familiar faces along the way
including Jason Statham Shaw Charlie's
Throne Cipher and we also meet Mr Nobody
stood a test who's played by Brie Larson
along with this is Alan Richardson's
aims who we learn leads nobody's agency
John Cena and Helmer and come back to
the slots-like guy pops up Pete Davidson
does a cameo and there's like tons and
tons of returning faces that end up
crowding the film we meet Danielle
mlki's Isabel who's tied in with the
franchise and Paul Walker's daughter
Meadow appears in the film too adding to
one of the many touching tributes
adente's plan is to make domenko suffer
and he wants to prolong this for as long
as possible because you shouldn't accept
death when suffering is owed we see his
backstory and learn that he's a
sociopath it was taken out of a psych
ward and this was due to his father's
influence I honestly thought right and
don't kick off but I thought he was
meant to be a sort of antichrist type
figure he is the son of the father and
we get constant cuts of the Christ
statue in Rio with his arms out which is
summing at Dante does too might be a
reach and as we touched on before we see
the scene from Fast Five from a
different angle the opening of the movie
reintroduces his dad and then we replay
the safe scene from a different angle
Dante is now part of the action too and
we watches a DH Jason Momoa is inserted
into the scene and see how he survived
this leads to Fast Five arguably
becoming the most important film in the
franchise with all of the events
revolving around that now as diesel
touched upon before this was originally
a two-parter that's luckily gonna start
off its own Trilogy if this one does
well either way because of that it kind
of teases why they took the direction
that they did for this one and it very
much ends on a cliffhanger with a crew
being lost divided and with a lot of
questions remaining unanswered the first
major one of these that you probably
have upon leaving the theater is how the
is Gisele alive yep that's right if
you're watching this video without
seeing the film then you'll probably be
surprised to learn that garlic is back
the movie features Letty getting
captured by by the agency and after some
help from Tess Cipher gets in to save
her from a black site located in
Antarctica the pair managed to make it
out and in the wilderness we see a
submarine emerging from the ice a woman
with binoculars pops out the top and
when she takes this down it's finally
revealed this is gal gadot's Giselle in
case you don't remember she first popped
up in the Fast and the Furious 4. as
someone of a villain before she came
back as an ally in past five last movie
Saw Han returning back from the dead and
Giselle was actually a love interest of
his at one point how the she alive
well because Wonder Woman 84 flopped and
James gun rebooted the DC
well if we go back to the runway scene
she died during that and sacrificed
herself in order to save Han her body
was never recovered but after Han was
killed by Shaw it made the entire thing
end on a tower note they actually have a
big scene with Sean Han coming face to
face with each other again and Han of
course has come back from the dead now
in the case of Giselle as I said her
body was never recovered and thus they
can bring her back reunite her with Han
and have them drive off into the sunset
off a cliff and then attach onto a plane
and fly away who knows though cause man
was getting matches on Tinder like I get
thumbs down when I make crap jokes I
think with the way that she fell back on
the runway though that she could have
landed on a car or something as we know
in the fast universe that learning on a
car is like dropping onto a safety mat
now there are other possibilities and
I've seen two times about how this could
be a twin sister or even a clone I think
that the latter is a little bit too
ridiculous but the former could be a
possibility and you never know with this
franchise however I do think that we'll
likely stick with Gisele and in the next
film learn about what happened it's
possible that they could reveal she was
connected to the submarine and Fast and
Furious 8 and this may be how they
retroactively show that she was there
all along now her coming back could also
tell us that some of the characters who
seem to meet their demise in the end
could come back too the film has Jacob
dying in a bid to clear a path but Dom
and though I really don't know how the
guy could have come back from that
explosion looking at everything in this
franchise you know it's still a
possibility I highly doubt they're gonna
pass up the chance to have the rocking
seen her on screen at the same time and
though it seems like there's no way the
guy gets out of it I think he's gonna
come back now as for Dom and Little
Brian the latter is taken by Dante but
Daddy Dom manages to save him the pair
gets stuck on a dam and their end is
planned to come with two old tankers
racing towards them however Dom drives
up the side and down the almost vertical
drop in what's easily the most
ridiculous thing I've ever seen you know
I'll tell you I was hi anyway tante has
bombs placed over the entire location
and after he activates it we close out
with their fate unknown he's clearly
planning to blow the dam and they might
do a Die Another Day where the pair just
winsurf away from there and there's also
the fate of the rest of the crew who are
describe as being occult with cars
though it seems like Ames becomes Dom's
buddy he is revealed to be a traitor and
he ends up shooting down that plane so
yeah I think obviously these guys are
gonna make it out there too because
they've got more lives than Captain
Scarlet and then being in this location
could be what helps Dominus son get out
there now before I saw this film I saw a
lot of people saying that this was the
franchise's infinity war and it does end
with everyone taking an l and the family
being at their lowest point will be
interesting to see how and if they will
work this into a Trilogy as judging by
this ending I think it works better off
as a two-parter rather than dragging it
out for another film you can't have a
cliffhanger and then another Cliffhanger
at the end of fast XX and yeah I think
it exploring things in Hobbs in short 2
and then tying in with another film
would be the best way to go sure does
drive off to go and save his mother and
I think hobbs's daughter could be pulled
into that too the ending is about the
family being at the lowest point and we
are meant to get the idea that divided
they fall so I think the main focus for
next time will be about bringing them
back together with potentially Giselle
leading this reunion when looking over
Dante's plans we learn that he's trying
to tear them apart and that he's even
going after Dom's friend's family which
I think would make some good spin-offs I
can't imagine that the next film will
culminate with everyone from over the
years finally reuniting and then fast
XXX will be our Noe home style film this
will be where all the forces unite to
fight this big bad and who knows they
might even have some of the baddies team
up for a big villain family as Dom says
in the film if you've got no family then
you've got nothing so we could see
family vs family for the finale of fast
in the family so yeah that's what I took
from the film and as for my thoughts I
think he can kind of tell what they are
off the tone of this review I remember a
couple of months ago that Vin Diesel
compared himself to J.R.R Tolkien and
the mythology of the Fast and the
Furious Universe pretty ridiculous and
when watching this it's actually
difficult to know whether the franchise
takes itself seriously or if it's well
aware of how stupid it is and just
Hamming it up there are a lot of jokes
here that feel like they're
tongue-in-cheek and though some actors
feel like they're in on it others don't
I think that everyone needs to just sit
down with vin one day and say look mate
we're making is in Kane yeah just
chill out I think this series needs to
decide what it actually wants to be and
make up its minor whether it wants to
lean into being stupid or go with a more
realistic tone like the first couple of
films had you've got these two sides to
it and these are exemplified perfectly
in vinimoa the form is acting like he's
auditioning for his Oscar nomination and
the latter is Hamming it up and just
going all out it's also the fact that
when everyone's doing all these dumb
stunts at there's absolutely no Stakes
to it it's difficult to feel like the
characters are in danger when we've seen
them do what they do unless you're kind
of left thinking it's all just a waste
of time so yeah you've got this weird
thing with that and then there's also
the fact that we've seen a lot of these
things before in the franchise I think
once they'd gone to space uh that was
kind of the peak of where things could
go and now they're just going through
the motions of rehashing the same dramas
and bringing back the same characters
from the dead with the announcement of
more sequels it feels never ending and
yeah the next few years are gonna be
interesting but should you go and see it
well if you're like the Fast and the
Furious movies then you already know
what the answer is if you don't then
there's absolutely no way this is gonna
win you around and I can imagine that if
you hate this franchise that it's gonna
feel like torture now I'm one of those
people who can fully take this out of it
because of how ridiculous it is but I
can also see the charm and humor in it
which I think keeps me interested Cena
Momoa ludicrous and Tyrese they all keep
their laughs going now at least stop the
movie from being as dumb as it should be
I don't want to give a score because
it's either one out of 10 or a 10 out of
10 depending on what you like but I'm
gonna give it yeah this is a new score
I've invented it's so bad it's it's
sometimes good writing so yeah that's my
thoughts on it let me know yours in the
comments below and yeah what did you
think about the film and where do you
think things are gonna go if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below and as a thank you you'll
get early access to videos every week
you also have our merch store over at
xeroedition.com which sells lots of
nerdy and spy t-shirts hats and more we
just launched a peacemaker and Drax
inspired t-shirt so if you want to head
over there and help us out then the
Link's in the description much
appreciated we are so thankful for your
support and if you want something else
to watch then a video is linked on
screen right now Jared's just done a
massive breakdown of the Mario movie
pointing out every Easter egg in it so
definitely head over there right after
this but out of the way thanks for
things through the video I've been Paul
and I'll see you next time take care
peace